[Music]
now what goes best with a delicious
chicken bowl an incredible sauce so
today
i'm going to show you how to add a
little moho to your chicken
all in just 10 minutes now oscar please
pan down these are chicken tenders
tenders in the u.s in the uk we know
them as sort of chicken fillets it's
that nice little strand that lays
underneath the chicken breast they are
so beautiful
quinoa this has just been boiled
seasoned and left to sort of steam in
its own beautiful stock a little bit of
mixed salad mojo sauce we're going to
give this a little bit of vibrancy
lots of coriander cilantro fresh yogurt
jalapeno with the vinegar the brine in
there and some lemon juice then we're
going to grate this beautiful sort of
exciting carrot and turn it into an
amazing salad with some orange juice and
zest
dukkha is a beautiful little middle
eastern spice that's going to help sort
of lift the flavor splat smoked almonds
touch the chili and this is going to
combine
into a beautiful dish let's now 10
minutes on the clock right first things
first with these tenders they are so
tasty
again
upsets me because you always see them on
kids meals and you know for babies but
adults should eat them because they are
incredible
lightly season them salt pepper a little
hint of chili just a hint okay now you
can poach them so to them i prefer to
steam them
simple little basket steamer in
parchment paper on and they take about
three and a half to four minutes to
steam they are so good on they go
now
from there
i want to make the mojo sauce first
this is a really simple delicious sauce
and it's got a lot of
oomph lift and flavor
okay
in there
i've got a nice sprinkling of coriander
cilantro
two nice tablespoons
of fresh yogurt
after that
a tablespoon
of some beautiful jalapeno
but
that juice is delicious
a couple of tablespoons in there and
that gives a little bit of sort of
vibrance to that sauce
fresh mint goes in
and then literally
a touch
of salt
a little touch of chili
a little touch
of pepper
and then
roll your lime
squash it down okay because that
is what gives it the acidity
and when we dress
the quinoa
and the chicken this sauce just comes
alive
a nice big squeeze
of lime juice in there lime or lemon i'm
preferring
lime
now
let that sit down
lid on and literally blitz that for 10
seconds
[Music]
[Music]
from there lift that up
taste that
it's so lovely it's got the heat
it's got the acidity
it's so good
really good
now the carrots
how do we take
these plain jane carrots and turn them
to something magical
you know when you think about cooking
carrots
exciting especially slow blazing
i prefer especially across the spring of
the summer to literally grate the carrot
and a nice raw
fresh
grated salad
now
i'm using some beautiful
purple carrots
and some normal carrots
and look
it forms a beautiful salad
and they just
taste sweet
you can use a mandolin
i prefer them grated because
they're a lot easier to digest
from there a little touch
salt
and pepper and then this beautiful
middle east spiced zucca it's fragrant
and it gives a sort of
a sort of welcomed lift
the sweetness of those carrots
get your beautiful orange
just zest
that origin
orange
carrots
spice
salt pepper
delicious
don't waste that look take that blood
orange off
squeeze that
over those carrots
be generous with that
okay
look at that orange beautiful and then
from there literally
just half a tablespoon of olive oil
now
mix that up
i like doing this literally too much
before the chicken cooks because it
keeps the crunch
but
the next day
even better
i've even sauteed it the next day it's
got that nice sort of sweet marinade
crunch check the seasoning
wow
that's so nice time please
halfway
this is such a quick
delicious ditch
it's so lovely now
quinoa
you know
not everybody's favorite but it's a
really nice starch and packed with
flavor
i like to sort of lightly dress it and
make it a little bit more exciting with
some olive oil
and fresh lemon juice
it's a sort of staple in the household
because it's incredibly healthy and it
just lightens up the load
especially
across the summer and again
it's sort of almost taken over from
lentils
it's healthy it's delicious and
it's got a bit of texture
very good
now well
four minutes in
they are done
okay before they come out
i'm just gonna put a touch of that
mohawk
sauce on there i'm just gonna coat the
top
literally
and let that sit there and almost
marinate
how do we dress this dish things are
gonna sort of sit naturally on the plate
for me the secret here
is not
to overdress the salad i've got a nice
light vibrant sauce i'm going to build
that salad up so start off with my basic
greens on the bottom
okay
then i'm going to take
some of my quinoa we'll sprinkle that
over
and literally
sprinkle and i mean sprinkle it
then i get my salad and just drop it
over
and you can see the sort of contrast of
the crunch
and that beautiful healthiness taking
place
tenders out
oh my goodness
these smell so good
and then literally sit on top
now i come back
my second little dressing
okay
a little bit of
rocket
a little bit of baby gem a little bit of
radicchio and it's almost like a sort of
a nice
80z of salad in there
as intriguing every step of the way
and then just literally sprinkle again
your seasoned
quinoa
and it just gives a lift now
i quite like a lot of sauce
it's a really nice sort of
vibrant way
of eating
i'm not gonna drain
the salad that's why i don't dress the
salad i let the actual ingredients dress
the salad
and so
finally the smoked almonds come on
now
you know this book was put together in
lockdown and i said ramsay in ten and
here we have the most amazing chicken
tender salad in eight change the title
ramsey in eight
boom
to all of you thank you for watching
ramsay intense if i went too quick i
apologize but slow it down now don't
forget to pick up ramsey inten cookbook
inspired by this series and trust me
you're going to come out a much better
chef and if you like this video don't
forget to subscribe to my amazing
youtube channel for more good luck